- I didn't really know
what entrepreneurship was,
but I believed that necessity
is the mother of invention.
I went out with those rocks.
Some people didn't think that was cool;
they had no need for me.
People slammed the door
on me, cussed me out.
We see so many people living day-to-day
with so much money and popularity,
but they haven't built inner wealth.
You know, people believe
that opportunity knocks,
you know, once or twice or annually.
I would say opportunity never knocks,
it's something you have to
go after with a vengeance.
We're trying to be the next
this person, or that person.
Be the next you, 'cause
everybody else is taken.
It's important to always be prepared.
I would say, if you stay ready,
you won't have to get ready.
- He's an American businessman,
investor, columnist,
author and motivational speaker.
He began his entrepreneurial
career at age six,
selling home-made lotion
and hand-painted rocks
door-to-door.
He was named on of the most
influential black men in America
by the National Urban League.
Here's Farrah Gray, and here is my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule #5 is my personal favorite.
I'm really curious to figure out which one
you guys like the most.
- How did you know, and how
did you have the wherewithal
at that age, that young,
to start selling things?
I mean, you said you started selling rocks
and people were like,
"Isn't that the rock that was by my door?"
- [Farrah] Right.
- And you sold it to them.
You have the wherewithal
to do something like that
and the courage.
- Well I think that comfort
is the enemy of achievement.
Growing up poor, when I
woke up, my mom was up.
When I went to sleep, my mom was up.
And my father was a
black leader and activist
and activism doesn't come with a salary.
So I realized, I said, "Wait a minute,
my mom had a heart attack, I said,
I must do something to help her."
So I went out and I sold oversized rocks
that I saw on the streets.
I would paint them and I would ask people,
"Would you like to buy this?"
And people would look at me
like, "Isn't that the rock
that was in front of my door?"
And I would say, "Yes, but it
can be used as paper weights,
book ends and door stoppers."
So I didn't really know
what entrepreneurship was,
but I believed that necessity
is the mother of invention,
so I got out there and I tried.
And I think that, of
course as grandma says,
"Nothing beats a failure but a try."
I was well introduced,
very early, to rejection.
When I went out with those rocks,
some people didn't think that was cool.
They had no need for them.
People slammed the door
on me, cussed me out,
all kinds of stuff.
But I just made a few
dollars on that door,
and then I said, "Well
let me go to this one,
I made some money there,
but the person in between cussed me out."
So you know, you kind of get
a chance to see very early
that not everybody's going to tell you no.
A reallionaire is someone who
is rich from the inside out.
We see so many people living
day-to-day with so much money
and popularity, but they
haven't built inner wealth.
So we see them getting
pulled over for DUIs,
going to jail, living really,
I think, on what I call
on a self-sabotage mission.
But what I've discovered
is that you have to balance
the inner richness and the outer richness,
and that's what a reallionaire is.
Someone who is rich from the inside out.
Most people say that you
have to be at the right place
at the right time.
I always say, no, you have to
be everywhere all the time,
because your visibility
is just as important
as your ability.
So, I think you have to show up.
And I find a lot of
times, even personally,
people are just not showing up anymore.
You can't win if you don't
play, so we have to show up.
- For example, right now
I find that people aren't
showing up for their opportunities.
You know, people believe that
opportunity knocks, you know,
once or twice or annually.
I would say opportunity never knocks,
it's something you have to
go after with a vengeance.
Living in Las Vegas, I even
give credit to people who
hit the jackpot there, because
at least they showed up
and put that dollar into
the machine for a chance.
So I think you have to give
yourself a chance and show up
in your relationships,
show up on your job.
Show up in life.
I had a teacher tell me, I
told her I was going to be
a millionaire entrepreneur one day.
I was seven.
She looked at me, she
said, "No you're not.
You're poor and you're family's poor.
You better go find somebody to work for."
And she kind of pointed towards McDonalds.
- Doesn't that make you go,
"Hey, wait a minute, no, no, no."
Doesn't that sort of
empower you even more,
or just give you the fuel
to prove that person wrong?
- Well at seven years old, it didn't.
I didn't know.
I remember going home to
my grandmother and I said,
"The teacher said I wouldn't be successful
and I couldn't be successful."
And she said, "Remember that
no matter what anyone says
to you, wake up every morning
honey, and she's going to say,
'Why not me?'"
"If you want millions, if you
want a mansion," she said,
and prophetically, she said
if you want to put it into
homelessness, and I've been the spokesman
for the National Coalition
for the Homeless.
When I found out the average
age of a homeless person
was nine and a half years old,
I knew that I could give back.
So she said, "Wake up
and say, 'Why not me?'"
She said, "If you believe in yourself,
you can accomplish anything
that you put your mind to."
I had a guy, he was 75 years old,
he called and he cussed me out.
He said, "Farrah Gray!"
I said, "Yes?"
He said, "I've been working
on my ta-da-da life."
Cut out the cuss words.
President Hall, I didn't cuss.
"I've been working on my ta-da-da life
and why is it that you
have money for and I don't?
I'm 75 years old."
I said, "Because, sir,
you have to find what God
put you here to do."
The richest place in the
world is the cemetery, why?
Because many of us have so many gifts.
We're trying to be the next
this person or that person.
Be the next you, 'cause
everybody else is taken.
You have dreams, you have
seeds of greatness within you.
You have the power to do
anything you want to do,
but you got to put your mind in action.
What I realized is that
there are two fights.
There's the fight to make the money
and then there's the fight to keep it.
We've seen a lot of
people hit the lottery.
William "Bud" Post, Evelyn Adams,
which I talked about in my
book, "Get Real, Get Rich."
They talked, we were
actually focused on the fact
that they made all this money,
they announced it to the world.
They talked about it and
the next thing you know,
they were broke.
You have people that won the lottery twice
and they live on public assistance.
Those two persons, now
one's in a trailer park
and the other's on public assistance.
So, it's really about
studying what others have done
as soon as they made money.
Most people think that when
you get that television show,
you're a big brand, that
money, that film opportunity,
that that's the time to relax.
I think it's actually time to work harder
and to multiply your success.
And you need to think,
I think, for generations
yet unborn.
So I had several mentors, one
gentleman introduced to me
numismatics at an early age.
He said, "Listen, young
man, if you really want
to make money,"
he said, "have your children's
children's children's
children thank you.
This is what you need to do!
Listen to me!"
I said, "Oh, okay, yes
sir, I listen to you."
He said, "Follow my instructions.
Invest your money in gold,
silver and platinum."
I said, "Alright."
I did that at a very early age.
So it allowed me to really
learn the precious metals
and the commodities market.
You know, I studied Berkshire Hathaway,
back when it was trading for a
few thousand dollars a share.
So, I started making very
strategic investments
because I realized, yes,
I may have this money now,
but what will happen ten years from now?
Ten years after that,
and now I'm 29 years old.
I've had great sustainability
and I can still call myself.
Some of my friends can't
call themselves that,
but I can still call myself,
by God's grace, a multi-millionaire.
So I'm very thankful.
- You were the youngest member
on the Board of Advisors
at the Las Vegas Chamber of Commerce.
What kind of pressure was
that, I mean, to sit at this...
It's a pretty big position, right?
Did you feel prepared and
worthy of being there?
Absolutely.
- Yeah?
- I think it's important
to always be prepared.
I would say, if you stay ready,
you won't have to get ready.
- So, being on the Board of the Las Vegas
Chamber of Commerce, basically
gave me a front row seat
of commerce and business and
also helping in assisting
in making decisions, and of
course, some people looked at me
like, "Isn't this kid, you
know, wasn't he born yesterday?"
And I would say, yes, I was born yesteday,
but I stayed up all night.
A lot of times, warriors
and successful people
have to continue sometimes
to walk alone, you know,
and operate to the beat
of their own drums.
- Yeah, that's true,
and you keep good people
around you, right?
- Absolutely.
I would say, like the
legendary rapper, Chuck D,
I say that if you can't
change the people around you,
change the people around you.
So I surround myself with good people.
And some people are so negative,
I would say that they can walk
into a dark room and develop.
- (laughing)
- You got to make sure
you surround yourself
with good people that build you up.
Build that all-star team,
because when you feel like
maybe I can't do this, or I can't do that.
'cause one thing that a lot
of people don't understand
about success, they ask me,
"You know, is what you do difficult?"
I tell them, what I do is easy.
I mean, it is a piece of cake.
The hardest part of what
I do now was the before.
It was believing that I could do it.
And that's the key.
So when you have people
that encourage you,
that build you up...
Because a lot of times,
what they say sinks into
your subconscious mind.
A lot of people say,
"Okay, what do you mean by
subconscious mind?"
You hear a song on the radio.
You know every single lyric to the song,
but when it goes off, you forget it.
So where were those lyrics?
They were in your subconscious mind.
Your dreams, some would say
it comes from your subconscious mind.
So when you hear people say
that you're not smart enough,
you're not good enough...
I had a teacher tell
me that I was too poor
and I wasn't smart enough
to be an entrepreneur.
And recently she called and cussed me out.
She did.
She said, "Why did you
put my name in your book?"
- (laughing)
- I said, "'cause I wanted
everybody to know who you were
so you couldn't crush
anyone else's dreams."
And like one of the greats
of our time once said,
"Never allow anyone's perception of you
to become your reality."
What is it that we do best?
I always say, find your
area of excellence,
becaues the two most
important times I've learned
is when we were born and when
we find out why we were born.
What did God put you here to do?
So ask yourself three questions.
First question, what comes easy to me
but harder to other people?
Second question, what would
I do and do it for free?
That one's tricky.
And the third question is,
how can I be of service
and how can I give back?
And I believe that once
you're able to wrap
those three things around
you and your philosophy,
the world, the marketplace,
will open up for you
and share your gifts and your talents.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Marcelin B asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the Comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the top ten rules
that we featured had the
biggest impact on you and why.
What are you going to change
now in your business or life
because you watched this video?
Leave it in the Comments and
I will join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.